there is only one question looming over
these docs how did a 3 000 ton ship end
up like this a vessel left tipping
dislodged from its Holdings in Dry Dock
it was a day of high winds and high
drama this part of Edinburgh embroiled
in an emergency
the staff that had been on the vessel
shared with me their shock
the complete disbelief that happened but
also the fact that they were amazed that
they'd actually got off that vessel as
walking wounded this major incident put
pressure on a e departments already
under strain officials say 33 people
were injured 21 of those were taken to
hospitals here in Edinburgh and
neighboring Fife 12 people were treated
at the scene
the MV petrol had been used for
specialist deep water searches but it's
claimed it's not been used in three
years covered creating what were
described as operational challenges yeah
it's very unusual for this sort of event
to happen
um the most serious Dry Dock
incident of the late was almost 20 years
ago in Dubai obviously it has been very
windy in Edinburgh today
um so that cannot possibly be ruled out
this is an investigation Gathering piece
questions are being asked as authorities
examine a vessel now detained as
evidence Connor Gillis Sky News
Edinburgh